it's the darkest deepest scariest place
I've ever been in my life and the
physical withdrawals if you're not
careful can actually kill somebody
[Music]
ami melon was dependent on painkillers
and nerve medication for nearly a decade
the final straw was when Amy's
medication caused her to blackout behind
the wheel with her teenage daughter and
a friend in the car this right here is
what changed my life
what is that this is concentrated
cannabis oil
within three months of ingesting oil I
was off all opiates took my last one
July 31st 2015 I didn't grow up around
drugs at all I'd only tried cannabis
like six times my whole life I didn't
drink alcohol I didn't even get drunk
till the first time till 2010 so I mean
I was totally knew it all that stuff the
owners of the dispensary we just visited
also grow cannabis for other patients I
see patients medicating for anything as
simple as migraines to back pain to
muscular dystrophy people who are
essentially trying to use anything other
than these other horribly addictive
substances they're coming to us a recent
study published in the Journal of pain
found that patients who started using
medical cannabis reported lower use of
opioids and a higher quality of life and
experts are seeing similar results
marijuana may be a better option for
treating chronic pain in many
individuals than opiates because this
class of drugs in contrast to opiates
does not affect respiration that's the
way people die from an opioid overdose
is they actually stop breathing the
federal government ranks marijuana as a
schedule 1 drug schedule one drugs are
viewed by officials as having no
medicinal benefits but for many people
like Amy there are many ways to measure
pain other than turning to another pill
and even now a lot of researchers don't
want to do research on cannabis because
it's a Schedule one drug and because of
that I think a lot of credible groups
that study pain have just decided it's
more trouble than it's worth because
marijuana is a schedule 1 drug it also
means that the cost of medical cannabis
isn't always covered by health insurance
people like Amy who wants to use
marijuana instead of pain pills and
paying a hefty price we spent over
$15,000 in less than a year I blew
through an inheritance that I had we we
went through our savings we can't
purchase a home we are in debt now
because of it
[Music]
I think there really are overwhelming
data suggesting that it can be helpful
in a lot of different medical conditions
not just chronic pain I am living I'm
breathing I'm laughing with my kids I
remember one of my friends saying she
said we have your back and to me that
meant a lot because I missed who I was
for so long if there's something you
really want out of life
you have to realize it's gonna be
painful but it's so beautiful on the
other side hey it's me doll Ian thanks
for watching this is a really important
story that I wanted to cover and I know
the solution is not as simple as
legalized weed and nobody will ever OD
again but it is pretty crazy that this
plant is still as illegal as heroin so
I'm going to be out in the fields again
soon what stories do you think we should
cover next if you've got ideas hit us up
in the comments below and I'll see you
guys again soon